welcome everyone to today's meeting of
the cabinet
both those that are participating and to
those who are watching on the live
stream
if members have technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you on call
today is james clapson
his number is five seven seven two zero
zero
it will also be at the top of the chat
thread for members if you need it
for those of you who are watching via
the council's youtube stream
please follow the instructions below the
video if there are any issues with the
live feed
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking to please mute your
microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen and i
will then make a note and go back to you
once the person speaking has finished
please note that we will be following
the usual cabinet protocols
in which other members of the council
usually only speak once on each item
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions
for the duration of the meeting
also please note that this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public
the meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
please can i ask the members of the
cabinet to confirm they are present in
the meeting when i read out your name
i will ask for the attendance of those
councillors who are participating in
order to speak under council procedure
rule
20.1 separately
councillor everett here
thank you councillor alvin here chair
thank you councillor duckworth
president chair and councillor yates
present chat thank you
the following members have asked to
speak under council procedure rule 20.1
when i say your name please can you
confirm that you're present in the
meeting
on item five i have counsellor wing
present chair thank you and on item six
i have counsellor stuart piper
here chair thank you and councillor
ghana
i'm here chair thank you very much are
there any other councillors present that
wish to speak under council procedure
rule 20.1
um yes chair please counselor ashby
could i speak under
uh agenda item six thank you
of course so just making a note of that
i am assuming as everyone is present we
have no apologies for absence
um declarations of interest does anyone
have an interest to declare any items of
business on the agenda this evening
okay on to the minutes item three
to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet meeting held on the 18th of
march 2021
copy attached to the agenda pack please
may i have a proposal and
a second i'm happy to propose
thank you i'll second it thank you very
much councillors
unless i hear any objection i will take
these as approved
which leads us on to item 4 which is our
corporate performance refresh
2021 through to 2024
the council's corporate objectives are
set out in the corporate statement
determine the strategic direction for
the council
our current objectives span environment
communities and growth
these influence annual operational
service plans and employees annual
appraisals
to ensure that the organization is
working collectively towards the same
goal
performance management is a key part of
the government corporate governance
process
and adds value by helping to ensure
accountability of the performance of the
council services
against the corporate objectives our
visibility in terms of accountability
and openness regarding our services
is of paramount importance the
availability of the information that we
hold
and the relevance of the information we
record helps our community to understand
not only what we wish to achieve
but what we are achieving and how we are
achieving it
relevant and regularly updated measures
help to encourage enhanced
accountability
and continuous improvement
the report presented to us this evening
sets out how we intend to refresh our
approach
to how we both monitor and report on
corporate performance
and also includes new performance
indicators
this new approach aims to provide the
public with clear and easy to access
information
on how key services are performing and
supports residents feedback that they
would like the council to be efficient
transparent and responsive
i thank all of those involved in this
work and the overview and scrutiny panel
for their engagement and feedback
surrounding this process
the panel will continue to play an
important role in the new performance
approach
above all we are responsible to our
residents
the way we work our aims and our goals
and our work towards them
should be visible trackable and
transparent
we know where we excel and where we need
to improve
because we are involved in the systems
every day
effective communication relies on
finding means and methods to make
systems and information
as easy to access for those unfamiliar
with systems
as it is for those who are deeply
involved in them
i believe that these measures indicate
our desire to do so and help greatly
towards that aim
i move the cabinet note the report
do i have a secondary
yep happy second thank you very much
unless i hear any objection i will take
this is approved
um can i speak here i've put a note in
the chat
oh yes sorry surely of course i know
it's difficult to follow because i've
been
um i i just wanted to say really that i
i welcome these um
these new methods of showing the
information and i think it's um i think
it's very encouraging that
um residents will be able to access
information on a dynamic basis and
in a more meaningful way i think it's
much better than just reporting
um quarterly to committees um and
overall i think this is a good piece of
work and we should thank the officers
for all
of an effort that's gone into devising
it i'm sure that it'll evolve over time
um but i think it's good and i welcome
it and i certainly be supporting tonight
thank you can i um speak as well chair
please
of course yeah and 100 agree
with what council ever said there um i
think from my side as the cabinet member
for community wealth building it's good
to see that we'll have a um
performance measure on that specific
item
and i believe it won't be ready until
later this summer but we will have a
kind of indicator about how
how much of tdc spend is spent locally
which is great to see and on top of that
the number of trees planted
uh greenhouse gas emissions and uh
um pollination statistics and data on
that
i think that's really useful and it's
the the right
direction we should be going so yeah
fully support what's going on
here thanks thank you very much uh
council alban i believe you have your
hand up
yes thank you chair i i don't repeat
what uh
my two colleagues have just said but i
think it's the what's what's been
important as
as well and shouldn't go we shouldn't go
on without saying it is the
is the uh overview of scrutiny
in input and i think which uh which have
been taken on board so um
i'm very pleased about that thank you
chair
thank you everyone for your
contributions and
that leads us on to item
five which is the procurement of the
works at royal crescent for amsgate
the council owns two buildings within
the historic royal crescent
situated in central gustin's road
ramsgate
this block overlooks the sea and the
westcliff promenade
these regency buildings are considered
to be a significant heritage value
and are also of significant financial
value with one flat currently listed for
500 000 pounds
and are grade two listed the two
buildings owned by the council
are numbers four to five fifteen and
nineteen to twenty three royal crescent
the buildings are divided into sixteen
and six flats respectively
of which 12 are tenanted and 10 were
sold as leasehold
under the right to buy legislation
before beginning i think it's important
for members to note what exactly is
being requested
and what is being moved there are four
recommendations within this report
that the first three are essential for
the safety of tenants and leaseholders
and need to be actioned quickly
is i think undeniable these three items
form the main body of this
recommendation
and have to move forward in order for
works to begin
so to refresh cabinet is being asked to
agree to
the letting of the contract for the
structural works and passive fire safety
works
at royal crescent ramsgate as detailed
in this report
subject to the approval of the required
budget by full council
the slippage of eight hundred thousand
pounds from the current 2020 through to
21
hra capital programme against
expenditure on this project during the
financial year 2021-22
and to recommend full council that the
additional budget requirement of 1.978
million
be allocated to the hra capital program
from the hra major repairs reserved
for the financial years 2022-23
and 2023-24
all of these are essential items and
need to move forward for the safety of
our tenants and leaseholders
the final item is equally significant in
terms of our relationship with our
leaseholders
and that is to accept the proposed
options for the recharging of apportion
costs to leaseholders
as set out in section 6 of this report
royal crescent is a significant and
complex building
both in terms of its list of status and
all that that entails
and in terms of the works that are
required
listed buildings require particular
process and all leaseholders are very
aware of the need of the works
and were also consulted about the
initial consults into the tender to
begin
assessment of the works by use kent
housing in 2018
i have had several concerns passed
forward to me over the past two days
and they encompass the following themes
the need for communication
and a perceived previous lack of it
concerns over the overall cost of the
works
the need for consultation and concerns
that flats owned by leaseholders will
become valueless
to address the first issue i do believe
that communication is vital
and that effective communication is best
achieved via an in-house service
and that is why i put forward the motion
to bring our housing service in-house
some while ago now
some of the communication issues we face
over this issue
stem from that difference in
communication
all i can do and promise on that front
is that as an in-house service we will
endeavor to provide a first-class tenant
and leaseholder service on all fronts
it is also worth noting that we have a
very effective tenant and leaseholder
group
who meet regularly with offices and the
portfolio holder to discuss their
concerns
leaseholders are more than welcome to
join and discuss any issues that they
may have
as residents from other blocks regularly
do so
we are committed to communicating openly
about this project as it progresses
as well as the previous consultation
about the appointment of consultants
we have sent out three newsletters
updating residents in recent months
and will continue to do this on a
regular basis as more details of the
project emerge
in relation to costs we will advertise
an open tender
to provide best value for money and
we'll also be using what is known as the
most economically advantageous tender
approach for this contract
which again should ensure that all costs
are as low as possible
to address the need for consultation
this will be happening but requires the
decision to tender for the works in
order to do so
without deciding to do the works we
cannot consult on the final scope of
works
or how those works are to be procured
and undertaken
so it is not that no consultation has
taken place it is simply that the
initial decision to tender for the works
has to happen
before the next stage of consultation
can begin
these buildings are of significant
heritage and financial value
that value will only increase with
necessary repairs
and any valuation currently would
reflect the need for significant
structural works
and that those works are necessary i
don't believe is in dispute by anyone
although these are high value flats the
two buildings in royal crescent are in
need of significant programmes of
maintenance
including structural and external
repairs fire safety works and repairs
the report details the estimated cost of
these works
and proposes the allocation of the
required budget and a timetable for the
completion of the work
the final specification of works
approach to tendering and costs
are subject to consultation with tenants
and leaseholders
especially in relation to phase three of
the works
the approach to tendering will ensure
that the market costs are properly
tested
so that we can achieve the best possible
value for our tenants and leaseholders
as listed buildings the works will also
require specific listed building consent
there are a total of 22 flats in the two
buildings
of which 10 have been sold under the
right to buy legislation and have
leaseholders
six of the ten leasehold flats are
sublet by the owners
the council has a duty to balance the
needs of both leaseholders and tenants
the costs linked to these works are
something we are acutely aware of
due to this the report includes
recommendations to allow leaseholders to
defer the payment of apportioned costs
including an option to fix the charge
against their property
payable in the event of a future change
of ownership and for the council to
consider writing off debts on change of
ownership
where the owner has insufficient assets
to pay the charge without causing
financial hardship
this approach is considered to be
equitable to both tenants and
leaseholders
whilst at the same time protecting
leaseholders from being caused financial
hardship
i think offering these measures is
necessary but i think we also need to
offer a greater degree of surety in
terms of the proportionality of charges
i fully understand the difficulty that
being faced with such high bills causes
for people
and i am determined that the council
will be reasonable in balancing the
needs of tenants and leaseholders
to ensure that we are choosing to
proactively
to ensure that we are choosing to
proactively refer these charges
to the first tier land tribunal so that
they can consider what is reasonable in
circumstances
referring these charges to an
independent external body scrutiny and
decision
is i believe both sensible and necessary
for both transparency and for the
security of both our tenants and
leaseholders
in the meantime the report recommends
that we proceed with the procurement of
a contractor
to complete the essential work and
recommends options for leaseholders to
pay whatever charges
the tribunal rules should be reasonable
this is a service that the first tier
tribunal offers
it will not hold up the process which is
important as vital works need to be
undertaken
for the safety and well-being of both
tenants and leaseholders
it will simply provide an independent
review of the reasonableness of the
charges when they are invoiced
once the works have been completed these
buildings will continue to provide high
quality affordable homes
to the residents into the future
so to recap the recommendations of the
report are as follows
firstly the letting of the contract for
the structural works and pacifier safety
works at royal crescent ramsgate as
detailed in this report
subject to the approval of the required
budget by full council
secondly the slippage of 800 000 from
the current 2020 to 21 hra capital
programme
against expenditure on this project
during the financial year 2021-22
thirdly that we recommend to full
council that the additional budget
requirement of 1.978 million
be allocated to the hra capital program
from the hra major repairs reserve
for the financial years 2022-23
and 2023-24 and that force
the proposed options for the recharging
of apportion costs to leaseholders
accepted are set out in section 6 of
this report
i move the recommendation set out in
this report do i have a second
second that chair thank you very much
cancer
everett
do i have anyone to speak and do 22.1
yes please cheer thank you very much
councillor inc
thank you councillor whitehead you i
mean you've covered a great deal a great
deal and answered and answered quite a
few questions
the leaseholders were recently informed
that they would need to contribute
extremely large amounts for serious
repairs to the building
and
sorry cancel the wing you seem to have
become muted
sorry as you as you can see in the
documentation they are a serious
life-changing amounts that i think any
of us
if we receive them would probably lose a
great deal of
sleep their main concerns you've covered
but i'll go over them again
for the leaseholders are they feel
there's a failure to appropriate
appropriately communicate uh with and be
consulted
as part of the process they have
concerns about historical neglect of the
building
by freeholders at previous freeholders
which will contribute to the present
situation so they feel as if they're
being
penalized for for historical failures
no detailed information on the scope of
the work cost estimates or what is
included in the works
i do believe kovid's probably not helped
this situation so
the question i'm going to ask on be on
behalf of
oh sorry you're muted again canceling
i think it would be i'm going to ask on
behalf of the leaseholders that the
item five be deferred until a
face-to-face meeting can be had
with the leaseholders and tdc as the
freeholder
i think if you were to give the
leaseholders a chance to hear your
speech that you've just made then it
would probably allay quite a lot of
their fears
so that's my question could we delay a
voting on item five to enable a
face-to-face meeting with the
leaseholders to try and address some of
the fears they have
thank you very much councillor wing
thank you um
to be clear if we were to delay any kind
of vote on item five
it would delay the significant and
fundamental works that need to happen to
the block because the main function of
item five
is to put out the tender for those works
to ensure that the structural needs of
the building
are dealt with and that the fire safety
works are carried out
also for a consultation to happen with
the leaseholders
the tender for those works has to go out
so a consultation
will happen as soon as the tender is
approved um so
the consultation with the leaseholders
can happen fully from this point
onwards but we have to approve the
tender before we can
do that um in terms of the structural
works
to my knowledge because these works were
commissioned
in 2018 i don't believe there has been
significant structural degradation since
that point but i'm
happy to take advice from mr porter at
this point if he's present
um but i think the main
issue here is that we ascertain
that sorry
um that the tender goes out
so that the works can be done so that
tenant and leaseholders are secure
and the knowledge that their building is
safe
um and that leaseholders are also aware
that
we are referring forward to the tribunal
ourselves
which means that they can be certain
that the tribunal is satisfied
that the charges apportioned are fair
and proportionate
i hope that answers your question could
i just request that
if it is approved it looks like it you
are going to approve that somebody could
meet with the residents arrange to meet
with the residents i folded the emails
as soon as possible
uh to try and begin that process of
relaying fears
and yeah and of course um i said in my
email this morning
i'm more than happy to meet with
leaseholders and residents
as our offices and the consultation um
will be ongoing throughout this process
um i believe
uh mr porter is wanting to come in at
this point
thank you chad i just wanted to add a
couple of points to that really
um the first one is that um uh
the uh once we've got approval to
proceed with
a program of works then we the next
stage is for us to design the detailed
specification
and finalize the scope of those works
and we
we would like to have a detailed
conversation with the tenants and
leaseholders about the final scope of
those works
and of course that will give tenants and
legal leaseholders the opportunity
if they feel that we've included
anything that they don't think should be
done
um for us to have a discussion about
that before we finalize
uh that position um and um
and that that potentially has uh the
um the outcome of that potentially is to
give us the opportunity to try and
reduce those costs if if we possibly can
so that
the costs quoted in the report are the
costs that came straight from the
consultants
um they i think they represent a worst
case scenario
um and so hopefully we can by working
with tenants and leaseholders
um over the next part of the project uh
find a way to reduce those costs
and we have committed already and we've
told the tenants and leaseholders we've
committed to
a monthly newsletter as well in addition
to any meetings that
people want to hold with us we've
committed to a monthly newsletter which
will continue to do that throughout the
project
thank you
thank you very much mr porter and thank
you councillor wink for your question
um are there any other speakers under
20.1 at this point
no in that case
unless i hear any objection i will take
these recommendations as approved
thank you very much which leads us on to
item six
which is the future of east kent hr
east kent human resources referred to as
ekhr
is a shared service that sits under the
umbrella of east kent services
it has previously provided hr services
to folkestone hive
canterbury than at andover it currently
provides services to vanet dover in
canterbury
folk standard hive having left the
shared service arrangement shortly after
its inception
in 2010 hr has been a shared service for
thanet canterbury andover since 2010.
the current collaboration agreement
between thanet canterbury and dover
dates from the 14th of october 2016.
it is important to note i think that
east kent hr is not a separate
organization
it has always been a shared service
shared services can have their
advantages
however historically localized
approaches tend to work better for areas
such as sanit
as they provide for local knowledge and
expertise and on the ground action and
integration
many things have changed within the
individual councils involved
that now reflect the need for a more
localized service for all three councils
canterbury decided to bring their hr
in-house on the 19th of april
citing changes in the way that they
provide for their hr needs
as they are already providing some hr
services directly to the marlow theatre
and to their new trading environmental
company
dover will be meeting on the 17th of may
to decide on the same issue
this is a proposal for planet to follow
in disbanding the east kent hr
partnership and to move our hr services
back in-house
there is a feeling across all associated
councils that hr is less a shared
service
more a shared resource and that its
current form it's not closely enough
involved in meeting the needs of the
three individual councils
one potential benefit of the proposal
will be the closer alignment of the
individual hr services
with the corporate priorities of each
council this proposal means that members
will have more involvement in issues
such as setting hr policies and
procedures which directly affect each
council's staff
members will also be able to have a
better understanding of issues which
affects staff
east kent hr staff are currently
employed by dover district council
and the costs are shared with canterbury
council and thana district council
so the three s 151 officers have
considered the impact of the change on
the finances of the shared services
the s151 officers and finance teams have
undertaken considerable work
in understanding the split of finances
their advice is that broadly speaking
the impact of the service returning
in-house will be neutral
it is proposed that staff will transfer
as closely as possible into roles
similar to their existing roles
and that the councils will take into
account as much as possible
their preferences as to where they
transfer to
this is in accordance with the
collaboration agreement that states that
either 2p shall apply in respect of any
of the shared services
or if 2p does not apply each council
shall still employ
any employee who returns to it from a
shared service
on the same terms as conditions as
applied immediately before termination
including full continuity of employment
it is proposed that the small payroll
service and management of the hr
software
will remain as a shared service and that
this team will remain at dover
the intention is that consultation will
take place over the spring and summer
and the service will come in house at
the beginning of september
i move the recommendations set out in
the report
do i have a seconder
i'll check on that chair
thank you very much are there any
members that would like to speak under
20.1
yes please chair councillor ashby
councillor piper police chief
councillor ghana thank you very much
um councillor ashby thank you chair
where are the councils have in the house
um
hr corporate governance matters come
come under the committee framework
within their general purposes committees
at prison as our hr is managed by east
kent
hr there are no such arrangements in
terms of reference to cover
this restructure i know from the report
that there is no mention on this please
could you advise if this has been
considered and how it will be handled
from a corporate
from a governance issue regarding
committee structure
thank you
do you want chair would you like us to
respond
to me to respond to that question or
i think it would probably be most
effective at this point um
i'm aware that governance and policies
cross over at various points but there
is a degree of separation here that i
think would be helpful
to discuss okay
ultimately uh you're correct currently
obviously gpc is a committee
of the council the role of gpc
will be to inform and
agree hr policies the actual delivery
of those policies will be the
responsibility
of header paid service and anybody who i
delegate that authority
to as part of bringing that structure
back into the council but it will be gpc
on behalf of the council who will be the
committee to agree policy for a
human resources at vanity council i hope
that
answers that question council ashby
yes that's that's and yes fully
understand
that and uh accept it thank you
thank you very much and thank you
councillor ashby um i believe councillor
piper was next
thank you very much chair uh council
ashby has covered
um at least one of the things i was
going to ask about
i'm just wondering what the average uh
man or woman in the street might feel
about any organization
that actually has the entirety of its hr
setup in-house um
i'm not particularly sure that that
is a a good idea um
it would present possibly a situation
where
if it is run by the senior officers of
the organization
those are the very people that employees
may wish to make a complaint about i
know there are separate systems for
dealing with
certain complaints but below a certain
level an employee
goes to the hr unit i personally would
think
hr should always be handled by a
separate company
i note the comment about the switchovers
being sort of cash neutral but it would
be interesting to know
how much we actually pay for an hr
service and is there has there been
or could there be any discussion for
example
uh with counters like ramsgate town
council who actually
employ an outside company to control
all the hr i i think it it creates a
bridge it creates a gap
between the employees and the senior
management if it's handled
elsewhere those are those were just the
points i i wish
to raise please jem thank you cancer
piper i believe
miss culligan would like to come in at
this point
thank you very much chair and thanks
very much councillor piper for your
comments
um just to say um
that the shared service is is our
hr service it's not a separate
organization
uh simply when the shared service was
set up
the four councils firstly followed by
the three councils when folkston
withdrew
decided to share their services so
they're not actually an independent
organization so there'll be no
difference
in simply we will have
that service in-house and
the other point is many many
organizations including many many
councils that i've worked for and other
councils
have an in-house hr service it's just a
different way of doing the same
thing um so it's yeah it's not a
separate organization
it's our organization that we delegated
to the shed
sorry it's our service that we
previously delegated to the shared
service
arrangement and that shared service
arrangement is
managed through the east kent services
arrangement which is itself
managed strategically by the three chief
executives so it's
a it's an internal arrangement that
we've simply
you know done as a shared service and
now we're bringing it back in-house
and chairman could i just add just to
provide a bit of reassurance to
councillor piper in respect of his
concern
around how complaints uh
between staff would be addressed that's
very
that's very much the role of policies
and procedures
to ensure that that separation where
necessary
is provided so just want to provide some
reassurance around that and obviously
gpc will have responsible for agreeing
those policies and procedures
uh as part of bringing in it back in
house but
in any hr service whether it's in
house or uh or as a shared service or
dealt with externally
would have to have policies and
procedures that belong to the council
and it's those policies and procedures
that are key to addressing
any of those concerns that you you
reflected
i hope that helps clarify that
thank you very much miss culligan um and
with homer and thank you very much for
the question
and councillor piper i believe that we
now have councillor ghana if i have the
order correct
you do yes thank you thank you um
just like i'm certainly not opposed to a
discussion about bringing the hr
services back in-house
um i am however concerned about the
timing
as we know there are currently a number
of formal processes in training relating
to the governance
and culture of the council and i believe
this item
should be paused until all outstanding
issues have been resolved
and the recently kicked off review of
governance and culture
has been completed and reported back to
council
i'd also like to add that um as i think
was mentioned a bit earlier
the general purposes committee
recognized last year
that it would be good for members to
have more of a say in hr policies
that directly affect than its staff and
i believe that any final
decision on this should be made should
be referred to and made by full
council rather than by the cabinet
thank you
okay um that's more of a statement than
a question so i'm not sure
what to answer within that um i would
like
um yes i'd like to bring um miss
culligan in this point
um to talk about the differences between
individual governance issues and overall
governance and hr
uh yes thank you very much chair thank
you uh councillor
ghana for your question um i mean
madeline may wish to comment on the
interplay with the
culture and governance review uh seen
cena's
she's been discussing it with grant
thornton and we're still waiting for the
terms of reference i believe to be
finalized
for that but um any ongoing
issues with the culture and governance
review i certainly don't
see how that would impact on bringing a
service which is
in effect our own service at the moment
back in house
it's simply a different arrangement
there will be
quite a long lead in time which we've
allowed for
to to enable as much consultation as
possible with the unions as much
consultation with
the staff affected and to
uh to bring you know to enable the staff
to transfer into the three councils a
smooth and as painless way for them as
possible so they won't transfer in until
the earliest in september
so you know there is quite a long period
between now and then but even then i
just
i don't see how doing that which is
basically
an arrangement of our services would be
impacted by the culture and governance
review i mean who um
grant thornton in doing that with you
would be able to discuss
talk to whichever staff or councillors
they wish and presumably if they wish to
talk to members of hr now or when they
transfer they can do that
um so i don't see any issue with that
and in terms of the decision making to
bring it back in-house
we agreed uh with um
canterbury and dover when we were
looking at this
that the decision is an operational
decision if you like
and it's a decision for cabinet which is
why we've brought it here it's not a
decision for council
but does that answer your question
councilor ghana
yeah i understand yeah thank you
i believe we now have councillor everett
yes thank you chair and i just wanted to
point out this issue about
um staffing policies and members ability
to get involved in them
because certainly in the discussions
that i've had um over the last 18 months
um with other group leaders the ability
of members to get involved in
the policies has been quite fundamental
and
that simply isn't possible under these
existing arrangements under which the
policies are delegated
to east kent hr and my experience of
shared services frankly tells me that
the democratic function here is
completely lost
i have attended these kent services
meetings
which i'm expecting to make a decision
as to whether
canterbury's theater
should relate to the hr service i have
no particular interest in what goes
on at canjabi's theater and i think
you're seeing in terms of this decision
tonight
which is a decision for our cabinet to
make but actually
um one of the councils was already
pulled out of it the other one's likely
to pull out of it next month
so there'll be nothing to stay a member
of um which is why
really it's completely pointless
discussion about whether whether we
should
whether we should defer it um
i think that this will be better um in
terms of councillor piper's comments
earlier about what rams gate town
council does well with respect i'd
suggest today that's because ramsgate
town council
is too small to viably employ its own hr
service
um phallic district council i think you
probably i don't
quite have any people that are at
ramsgate town council now but i would
think
it must be 25 to 30 times the size in
terms of personnel
of ramsgate town council and therefore
economically it makes sense
for tdc to run its own service and
certainly when i've worked for big
organizations
they've always had their own hr function
and that hasn't prevented people
raising grievances and proper process
being extended and i can assure you some
of the organizations i've worked for
governance was nothing like as good as
it is at that district council
because in the private sector sometimes
anything goes
so i i'm totally supportive of this and
i know that it won't take effect until
september
um the external review that's been
referred to will do its work it will
look at everything that he needs to look
at
i don't think it's got any relevance to
this matter and i'm fully supportive for
bringing
hr back in house and i think the council
will be better served
by an in-house service thank you
thank you councillor everett um i
believe we now have councillor alban
yeah thank you chair um council rebels
basically covered a lot of what i was
going to say
however um i wanted i just wanted to
to let council piper know that uh since
1974 until 2010 nintendo district
council
had his own hr department as a previous
officer
as a privilege officer and certainly as
uh certainly is a
former representative of the staff at
thanet district council
i was firmly and the staff are firmly
against the hr
being put out to a shared service
and i'm i'm chuffed actually that is
coming back in house
um i can't see that that
there certainly isn't any uh conspiracy
theories uh that some of our members may
have as to why this is being taken place
now
this has nothing to do whatsoever
with any ongoing issues that that are
currently take
taking place and uh i fully support this
chair thank you
thank you very much councillor alban uh
to recap the recommendations
firstly the east kent hr should be
disbanded and the hr service returns
in-house
secondly the authority is dedicated to
the interim head of shared services
in consultation with the chief executive
and leader to carry out all necessary
processes to give effect to the decision
thirdly that authority is given to the
interim head of shared services
to sign off and enter into any
agreements necessary to give effect to
the decision
this includes but is not limited to
novation of contracts between
any of the three councils and any third
parties
and finally to recommend to council the
east kent shared services collaboration
agreement
dated the 14th of october 2016
is amended to reflect the changes set
out in recommendations
one through to three unless i hear any
objection i will take recommendations
one to three is approved
and four is recommended for submission
to council
and that i believe moves us to the close
of the meeting
that concludes the business for
tonight's